en colère quel plan d'action pour des
résultats concrets à la demande du
groupe les républicains je vous rappelle
que dans ce débat le gouvernement aura
la faculté si le juge nécessaire de
prendre la parole immédiatement après
chaque orateur pour une durée de 2
minutes l'orateur disposera alors à son
tour du droit de répartie pour une
minute monsieur le ministre tout d'abord
bonjour vous pourrez donc si vous le
souhaitez répondre après chaque orateur
une fois que celui-ci aura retrouvé une
place dans l'hémicycle la parole est
tout d'abord à l'orateur du groupe qui a
demandé ce débat madame Alexandra
borchio fantôme pour le groupe les
républicains et vous avez 8 minutes
chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
harceler tu
deux verbes côte à côte pour désigner ce
phénomène dramatique qui traduit un mal
français un laxisme sans précédent face
à un fléau de société qui tue le
harcèlement mes chers collègues touche
en France un million de jeunes chaque
année c'est-à-dire un jeune sur 10 qui
sont autant de citoyens dès la
socialisation née le rejet et c'est
lorsque l'enfant apprend à grandir à
l'école primaire dans sa fragilité qu'il
est davantage concerné à l'âge de ses
premiers apprentissages le harcèlement
scolaire concerne également leur famille
leurs proches leur entourage autrement
dit au sein de notre assemblée par
exemple ici et maintenant
des dizaines de nos enfants ou de nos
petits-enfants subissent ce qu'aucun
enfant ne devrait subir c'est la raison
pour laquelle notre groupe politique les
républicains a souhaité inscrire ce
débat à l'ordre du jour dès le plus
jeune âge un nombre de plus en plus
conséquent de mineurs est amené à
connaître de la cruauté humaine et à
perdre foi en autrui ce lien de
confiance pourtant fondamental dans
l'épanouissement d'un individu une
réalité qui dépasse souvent
l'entendement une réalité trop
régulièrement traitée comme un simple
fait divers mais chaque prénom de
victime leur histoire leur souffrance et
leur douleur nous ne pouvons les oublier
suicide ou homicide on sait finalement
jamais vraiment qualifié comment
qualifier l'acte d'un enfant qui se
donne la mort car pousser à bout par
leurs camarades que ce soit dans le
cadre éducatif ou par le biais des
nouvelles technologies ou des réseaux
sociaux
pourtant le camarade à l'origine est un
terme militaire qui renvoie au partage
et à la fraternité il naît de camarades
que s'il s'unissent dans la même cordée
disait Saint-Exupéry l'école est ce lieu
où la société a décidé de confier à des
adultes la transmission des valeurs de
savoir de savoir-vivre et de savoir
faire à ses enfants c'est là que la
société dessine son avenir en formant
les adultes de demain allez à l'école ne
doit jamais devenir une contrainte
émotionnelle mortifère qui ne laissera
que des séquelles voir des stigmates
chez ceux qui ont été victimes de
harcèlement ce débat est donc
l'opportunité de poser des mots sur des
incompréhensions que victimes parents
mais aussi une forte majorité de nos
concitoyens ne peuvent plus supporter il
est donc urgent de tout mettre en oeuvre
pour remédier à cela comment ne pas être
choqué lorsque l'on sait que l'enfant
harcelé et donc brisé dans sa
construction
identitaire doit quitter
grandes écoles tandis que celui qui a
fait du mal peut y rester impunément
c'est ce qu'a conduit notre collègue
Marie merci a déposé une proposition de
loi visant à poser le principe d'une
mesure d'éloignement du harceleur pour
protéger la victime afin qu'elle ne
subissent pas cette double peine une
mesure de bon sens monsieur le ministre
puisque vous l'avez retenu si on en
croit vos annonces dans la presse ce
matin
l'impunité dans laquelle vivent les
auteurs des faits de harcèlement doit
cesser impunité qui les mène à
reproduire leurs actes de victimes en
victimes à ne pas comprendre et mesurer
l'impact et la gravité de leurs
agissements il faut donc les prendre en
charge de manière appropriée et
n'oublions pas les témoins qui peuvent
être traumatisés par la violence qu'ils
ont observé et peuvent développer un
sentiment d'impuissance l'école a bien
évidemment un rôle à jouer dans la lutte
contre le harcèlement mais c'est avant
tout l'éducation qu'on donne à son
enfant qui va déterminer la personne
qu'il sera envers les autres ne n'y ont
pas cet sans qu'il ne soit toutefois
fait de faux procès en accusation aux
parents afin que l'état des lieux
dressés ne soit pas une équation dont il
manquerait une inconnue les parents
doivent également être impliqués dans la
prévention en étant sensibilisés et
informer sur les différentes formes de
harcèlement scolaire et en étant
encouragé à diagoler avec un dialoguer
avec leurs enfants j'ai l'espoir que
chacune des 17 prises de parole au sein
de cette hémicycle aujourd'hui favorise
le déclic afin que nous parvenons enfin
à protéger nos enfants harcelés au Sénat
la mission d'information sur le
harcèlement scolaire et le
cyber-harcèlement estiment qu'il est
temps de détecter et traiter ce fléau
autour de ce qui doit constituer
désormais une grande cause nationale et
non pas une journée nationale instaurer
un jeudi de novembre comme un rappel
annuel où chacun dénonce le harcèlement
scolaire 24 heures durant avec tout le
pathos que l'on connaît
faisons-le pour les parents de Lucas
dans les Vosges ou encore pour la
famille d'ambre dans la Drôme pas pour
leur propre enfant puisque c'est déjà
trop tard ils ont préféré mettre fin à
leur calvaire en se donnant la mort
parce que notre pays n'a pas su les
écouter ni les protéger nous devons donc
aller plus loin dans la prévention et la
formation auprès des acteurs de
l'éducation nationale et des familles
malgré les avancées de la loi du 2 mars
2022 et du programme phare de tels
drames en 2023 traduisent un terrible
échec collectif une injustice
inacceptable les chiffres montrent que
ces mesures sont insuffisantes et
relancent les défaillances du système
l'autorité judiciaire doit faire de la
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire une
priorité de sa politique pénale afin de
se saisir de la nouvelle infraction
définie les signalements doivent être
pris au sérieux le harcèlement scolaire
ne doit plus être considéré comme une
histoire entre gamins qui aide à grandir
ou des jeux sans importance à Menton
dans mon département des Alpes-Maritimes
Anna je cite n'en peux plus d'aller au
collège chaque matin avec la boule au
ventre et ça fait 6 mois que ça dure ce
combat ne se mène pas seul il est temps
que nous prenions tous ensemble des
mesures supplémentaires pour prévenir et
combattre le harcèlement scolaire mais
il est primordial de lever le voile sur
ce phénomène et d'oser en parler car on
a beau mettre en place tout un arsenal
de mesure si les gens ne veulent pas
voir alors tout cela ne servira à rien
et dont les a détecter les victimes les
prendre en charge et gérer les
harceleurs l'école est aussi ce lieu
privilégié d'observation de repérage
d'évaluation des difficultés scolaires
personnelles sociales familiales et de
santé des élèves enfin pour conclure je
veux saluer toutes les personnes qui
s'engagent au quotidien dans la lutte
contre ce fléau leur engagement est
essentiel pour que nous puissions
avancer ensemble dans la bonne direction
avec comme seul et unique objectif
l'intérêt de l'enfant pour que l'école
ne soit plus une zone de non-droit et
pour que l'enfance ne rime plus jamais
avec violence
merci chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez deux
minutes pour répliquer si vous le
souhaitez
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice borque au fond de
vous avez souhaité inscrire à l'ordre du
jour à un débat sur le harcèlement
scolaire et je vous en remercie car j'ai
placé la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire comme une priorité de mon
action indispensable à la réussite
scolaire longtemps dans l'angle mort du
système scolaire il faut bien le
reconnaître la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et depuis 2017 un
enjeu fort du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse qui se
mobilise très fortement et je m'inscris
dans la continuité de l'action qui a été
engagée vous je rappelle bien sûr la loi
du 26 juillet 2019
dites loi sur l'école de la confiance
qui inscrit le droit à une scolarité
sans harcèlement la loi du 2 mars 2022
qui pénalise le fait de harceler et puis
à la rentrée dernière la généralisation
du programme PHARE dont nous aurons
l'occasion de reparler
qui permet une mobilisation des
communautés scolaires nous en sommes
c'est un chiffre que je vous donne à 60%
des écoles qui sont engagées dans ce
programme et 86% des collèges ça n'est
pas encore 100% nous avons encore
évidemment du chemin à parcourir nous
avons aussi du chemin à parcourir du
côté des lycées puisque j'ai annoncé que
de du côté des lycées le programme PHARE
sera étendu à partir de la rentrée 2022
nous avons beaucoup à faire à tous
égards et dans les échanges que nous
allons avoir j'aurai l'occasion de
préciser un certain nombre de mesures
l'extension du programme PHARE je l'ai
dit et puis par ailleurs je l'ai annoncé
également ce matin dans certains cas et
en dernier recours la possibilité de
scolariser l'élève harceleur dans un
autre établissement pour ceux qui
concerne les établissements du premier
degré nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
pardon
la parole est à présent à notre collègue
Monsieur Alain Marc du groupe les
indépendants et vous avez 5 minutes
chers collègues
merci Madame le présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues chaque
année ce sont près d'un million
d'enfants qui sont victimes de
harcèlement personne n'était Parné si
chaque situation de harcèlement est
unique les conséquences sont nombreuses
et se ressemblent baisse de l'estime de
soi isolement progressif des camarades
troubles du sommeil défiance envers les
adultes décrochage scolaires ont et
culpabilité si chaque situation de
harcèlement est un drame il arrive même
bien trop souvent que les cas de
harcèlement virent à la tragédie
l'actualité se charge de nous le
rappeler cruellement on compte environ
20 suicides d'enfants par an j'ai bien
entendu une pensée pour le jeune ducat
décédé le 7 janvier dernier la
récurrence de ces drames souligne notre
échec collectif à enrayer définitivement
le fléau du harcèlement à l'école
aujourd'hui la situation se complique
car les frontières entre le cadre
scolaire et la sphère familiale privée
se brouille avec l'événement avec
l'avènement des réseaux sociaux les
jeunes victimes n'ont plus un instant de
répit le harcèlement vécu en classe se
poursuit à la maison jusque dans la
chambre censé être le refuge intime et
protecteur par excellence les moqueries
les humiliations les insultes continuent
à pleuvoir par message privé ou bien à
la vue de tous dans des publications
devenant parfois virales la peur doit
changer de camp
c'était justement le signal envoyé par
la mission d'information sur le
harcèlement scolaire et le
cyber-harcèlement en juin 21 dont ma
collègue Colette Milo était la
rapporteur
et dans notre collègue Alexandra
morchiaumonti vient de rappeler les
principaux éléments le constat est sans
appel aucun établissement scolaire aucun
département n'était Parné on estime
aujourd'hui entre 800 000 et 1 million
de nombre d'enfants victimes de
harcèlement scolaire chaque année cela
représente l'enfant sur 10
ces chiffres sont effrayants et nous
engagent à réagir urgemment ce rapport a
présenté une série de pistes d'actions
concrètes elle s'organise autour de
trois axes clairs destinés à guider
l'action publique la prévention la
détection précoce et enfin de traitement
des cas de harcèlement le rapport
insistait notamment sur la gravité du
cyber-harcèlement face auquel les
parents et le personnel éducatif reste
bien souvent démunis la prévention des
jeunes et cruciales la formation des
adultes est essentielle nous devons
développer collectivement de nouveaux
réflexes de protection pour intervenir
dès l'apparition des premiers signaux
d'isolement ou de persécution c'est
d'autant plus important à l'école
républicaine elle doit être un lieu
d'épanouissement et d'apprentissage pour
nos jeunes et non le théâtre de brimades
d'humiliation et de violences physiques
ou verbales
tout le monde doit se mobiliser
éducateur par an enfant pouvoir public
l'État joue un rôle essentiel pour
impulser une vaste stratégie de lutte
contre ces violences dont souffrent nos
jeunes à l'école nous devons tous être
au rendez-vous dès lors monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous énoncer avec
précision vous ambitions et votre
calendrier pour lutter avec efficacité
contre le harcèlement scolaire et le
cyber-harcèlement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre pour réplique
merci Madame les présidentes mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Marc je vous remercie de vos
propos et nous sommes évidemment en
accord sur la gravité des conséquences
du harcèlement vous avez rappelé les
drames que nous avons connu et j'ai une
pensée bien sûr pour les victimes que ce
soit les élèves qui meurent chaque année
de harcèlement ou que ce soit les élèves
qui plus silencieusement je dirais sont
affectés sur le long terme par des
pressions ou par des trajectoires
scolaires Henri la question du
cyber-harcèlement est évidemment très
importante je rejoins les propos que
vous avez tenus je rappelle à cet égard
l'existence d'un numéro le 30 18 numéro
gratuit qui est très efficace j'ai
visité la plateforme qui permet de
répondre y compris à des messages de
panique de collégiens ou de leur famille
lorsqu'il s'agit de bloquer tel ou tel
photographie intime ou telle ou tel
boucle de message on y arrive très bien
et je veux saluer évidemment l'existence
de ces deux numéros dont je signale
qu'ils seront désormais systématiquement
présents dans les carnets de
correspondance des élèves à partir de la
rentrée le programme PHARE auquel vous
avez indirectement fait allusion à
donner ses preuves ou à fait ses preuves
dans les 6 académies où il était
expérimenté jusqu'à l'année dernière il
est donc généralisé à partir de la
rentrée dans les proportions que j'ai
indiquées nous avons encore du chemin à
faire de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit
d'abord de former au moins 5 adultes
référents par établissement scolaire
plus des élèves ambassadeurs ce sont
souvent les élèves qui sont à même de
détecter les changements de comportement
de leur camarades ou telle ou telle
situation de harcèlement et de rapporter
les faits auprès des adultes formés nous
sommes en dans un vaste programme de
formation des adultes et puis ensuite il
y a le traitement des situations de
harcèlement ou l'on essaye puisque ce
sont des enfants que nous avons une
mission pédagogique de
d'amener l'élève harceleur à reconnaître
ses torts et enfin la possibilité de
sanction que ce soit par le biais de
conseils de discipline ou que ce soit
par la nouvelle disposition que j'ai
indiqué à l'instant
je vous remercie
Monsieur Thomas docius c'est la parole
pour le groupe écologiste vous avez 5
minutes chers collègues
madame la Présidente Monsieur ministre
mes chers collègues je vais commencer
par une petite digression puisque nous
allons passer le reste de la journée à
parler de l'école et de ce qu'il entoure
et alors que nous aimerions qu'elle soit
un sanctuaire préservé des violences de
notre société la semaine dernière ce
sont les violences policières qui se
sont invitées dans un lycée de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ou un élève a
été plaqué au sol par quatre policiers
menottés en commissariat relâché sans
poursuite pendant que d'autres élèves
étaient menacés par des agents les
visant avec des flash-ball nous aurions
aimé monsieur le ministre une réaction
de votre part devant cet usage
manifestement 10-3 portionnés de la
force mais revenons au débat du jour et
nous sommes aujourd'hui une nouvelle
fois réunie pour débattre d'un fléau
national le harcèlement scolaire
ce n'est pas la première fois loin sans
faut mais il convient comme à chaque
fois de faire état des chiffres pour
bien mesurer l'ampleur du phénomène
d'après le rapport de la mission
d'information portée par nos collègues
c'est natrices Colette mélo et Sabine
van egg la situation est absolument
dramatique entre 800000 et 1 million
d'enfants en sont victimes chaque année
ce qui représente 2 à 3 élèves par
classe et 6 à 10% des élèves y font face
au moins une fois durant leur scolarité
ce qui en fait une menace et une
souffrance particulièrement difficile à
vivre et à cerner c'est qu'elle ne se
cantonne pas aux enceintes des écoles le
harcèlement rattrape les élèves jusque
dans leur foyer via les réseaux sociaux
et toute la sphère numérique le cycle
des violences ne s'arrête jamais les
victimes ne connaissent aucune pause
aucun répit dans leur souffrance et cela
échappe à la sphère parentale tout en se
passant parfois au domicile il convient
de s'attaquer aux causes de nombreux
élèves sont harcelés en raison de leur
genre de leur handicap de leur couleur
de peau ou de leur orientation sexuelle
et les conséquences sont parfois
terribles définitives
inacceptable en janvier dernier le
suicide de Lucas 13 ans harcelé en
raison de son homosexualité montre à
quel point l'homophobie et la
discrimination continue de tuer à la
rentrée 2022 le programme de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire phare qui
prévoit notamment aux différentes
actions de prévention vous l'avez dit a
été généralisé à l'ensemble des écoles
élémentaires et des collèges monsieur le
ministre vous affirmiez en novembre et
vous venez de le réaffirmer que ce
programme avait obtenu d'excellents
résultats nous aimerions vous croire sur
parole mais nous avons un problème en ce
moment avec la sincérité de la parole de
l'ensemble du gouvernement sur quels
critères sur quel élément vous
basez-vous alors que le programme PHARE
prévoit un mécanisme d'évaluation aucune
évaluation détaillée n'a jamais été
communiquée publiquement de leur côté
plusieurs associations et syndicats
pointent du doigt de nombreux
dysfonctionnements notamment le
déploiement inégal du programme sur le
territoire la formation superficielle
l'absence de communication sur le numéro
d'urgence le manque cruel de moyens
humains et financiers le collège du
jeune Lucas qui s'est ôté la vie avait
d'ailleurs mis en place ce dispositif au
sein de son établissement en vain le
manque de moyens humains est financier
dédié à la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire va au-delà du programme PHARE
prenons l'exemple de la médecine
scolaire jalertais déjà sur ce point
l'année dernière au moment de l'examen
de la proposition de loi sur le
harcèlement scolaire l'état de la
médecine scolaire dans notre pays est un
scandale il y a environ 900 médecins
scolaires et 7700 infirmiers et
infirmières scolaire pour 12,5 millions
d'élèves dans notre pays soit un médecin
pour 14000 élèves et un infirmier ou
infirmière pour 1600 élèves cela
représente une chute des effectifs de
15% en 5 ans la pandémie n'a pas été un
déclic le quoi qu'il en coûte s'est
arrêté à la porte de l'école voilà des
professionnels en contact des élèves qui
pourraient identifier des situations à
risque engagés le dialogue et alerter
mais avec les moyens humains aussi
dérisoirs il nous est impossible de leur
confier ses missions
enfin vous avez récemment annoncé
monsieur ministre plusieurs mesures
contre les LGBT phobies à l'école comme
le déploiement de campagne de
sensibilisation et la généralisation
d'observatoire de lutte contre les LGBT
phobies c'est une première étape que je
salue mais qui est loin d'être
suffisante pour endiguer le dépôt le
fléau des discriminations lgbt-fobe à
l'école je m'interroge également quand
au moyen qui seront dédiés à ces
dispositifs et leur pérennité comment
lutter efficacement contre le
harcèlement scolaire lgbt-foop si les
moyens mis en place ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux nous le savons il n'y
a pas de solution simple pour lutter
contre le fléau protéiforme du
harcèlement scolaire nous avons bien
conscience que les solutions sont
multiples et au croisement de l'école et
de la société qui l'entoure mais il faut
passer à la vitesse supérieure investir
plus dans la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire que ce soit à travers la
médecine scolaire ou des politiques de
prévention contre la montée des haines
c'est investir dans l'apaisement de
l'école et de la société en général il
en va de notre responsabilité je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre vous avez deux minutes pour
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur docius vous avez raison ça
n'est pas le premier débat qui se tient
dans cette hémicycle sur la question du
harcèlement mais nous avançons et comme
vous l'avez dit à l'instant il n'y a pas
de solution simple nous sommes sur un
chemin un chemin de progrès mais il n'y
aura pas de baguette magique qui d'un
seul coup fera disparaître ce fléau vous
avez justement dit que souvent le
harcèlement pèse sur un élève ayant une
vulnérabilité réelle ou supposée une
différence réelle ou supposée le cas des
élèves LGBT est un bon exemple nous
avons eu des un drame terrible il y a
quelques semaines et je suis très
mobilisé sur cette question nous
préparons activement la journée
internationale du 17 mai ce sera
l'occasion d'une grande campagne vous
avez mentionné la création des
observatoires notre partenariat avec
l'association SOS Homophobie et d'autres
associations qui sont très mobilisées
sur la question vous avez posé la
question des évaluations de l'évaluation
des expérimentations qui ont eu lieu
dans 6 académies pendant deux années
c'est
ces expérimentations sont en évaluation
il y a une équipe de chercheurs qui
travaillent sur la question on sait déjà
de manière empirique que le règlement
des cas de harcèlement à donner de bons
résultats pas tellement la baisse du
nombre de cas puisque précisément le
fait de se mobiliser fait que ça fait
apparaître des cas qui sinon resteraient
sous la ligne de flottaison nous sommes
mobilisés y compris via la médecine
scolaire le point que vous indiquez sur
la médecine scolaire est intéressante
parce que un tiers un banquière des
postes de médecine scolaire ne sont pas
pourvues je pourrais nous pourrions
doubler le nombre de postes de médecine
scolaire que ça ne changerait rien au
nombre de médecins c'est pourquoi nous
préparons activement avec le ministre de
la Santé un plan de médecine scolaire
nous attendons pour cela le rapport qui
viendra de trois inspections générales
et qui sera l'occasion de mettre à place
cette question importante
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Julien barge Danton du groupe RDPI et
vous avez 6 minutes chers collègues
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de quoi parle-t-on du
harcèlement et essentiellement en fait
du harcèlement entre père puisque c'est
la forme la plus répandue de la violence
en milieu scolaire qui est caractérisée
par un usage répété de la violence
physique des moqueries des insultes ou
des humiliations cela concerne et cela a
été rappelé à peu près 800 000 à 1
million d'élèves par an soit
potentiellement 10% des élèves qui sont
concernés et avec les événement du
numérique et bien
cet harcèlement se prolonge via les
réseaux sociaux et y compris la sphère
privée ni échappe plus alors depuis 2017
le gouvernement les gouvernements a pris
vraiment la mesure de cette difficulté
de ces graves difficultés qui d'ailleurs
se sont marquées par un drame récent que
vous avez tous cité avec le jeune Lucas
depuis 2018 je vous rappelle que les
portables sont interdits à l'école et au
collège avec une proposition de notre
collègue Richard Ferrand d'ailleurs qui
avait été adopté en procédure accélérée
et c'est évidemment une forte une forte
lutte contre le cyber-harcèlement que
bien sûr de lutter contre l'utilisation
trop précoce et traumative de ce genre
d'instruments par nos enfants cette
élément là était le premier et
extrêmement important en 2019 la loi
pour l'école de la confiance est venue
en effet créer ce droit à une scolarité
sans harcèlement aucun élève ne doit
subir de la part d'autres élèves des
faits de harcèlement ayant pour objet ou
pour effet une dégradation de ces
conditions d'apprentissage susceptibles
de porter atteinte à ses droits et à sa
dignité ou d'altérer sa santé physique
ou mentale la même année le gouvernement
a annoncé l'extension des horaires de la
plateforme net écoute dédiée aux
cyber-harcèle harcèlement le plan de
lutte contre le harcèlement phare a été
souvent cité par les opérateurs
précédents et par vous monsieur le
ministre il est désormais obligatoire
dans tous les collèges et toutes les
écoles élémentaires depuis la rentrée
2022 il implique à la fois les adultes
et puis les enfants notamment avec les
élèves ambassadeurs ainsi que les
parents qui sont associés c'est donc un
dispositif 360 degrés qui concerne toute
la communauté éducative l'année dernière
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
Erwan Balan a créé un nouveau délit de
harcèlement scolaire qui sanctionne les
élèves ont aussi des étudiants ou les
personnels des établissements scolaires
et universitaires qui sont reconnus
coupables de harcèlement c'est désormais
passible de 10 ans de prison et de
150000 euros d'amende en cas de suicide
ou de tentatives de suicide de la
victime du harcèlement il y a donc une
panoplie pour lutter contre le
harcèlement et qui a été complété ces
dernières années depuis 2017 et bien sûr
cela paraît insuffisant parce que la
situation est toujours dramatique et ces
phénomènes sont encore trop répétitifs
et donc effectivement d'autres d'autres
changements sont vraisemblablement
nécessaires alors il y a une proposition
de loi une proposition de loi de notre
collègue LR mari merci qui pose le
principe de la mesure d'éloignement du
harceleur pour protéger la victime c'est
une question importante l'éloignement
systématique qui doit-il concerner
est-ce que c'est pas une double peine
s'il concerne aussi la personne l'enfant
qui a été victime il y a eu aussi une
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Sabine fanungheg on voit donc que le
Parlement se saisit largement de cette
question monsieur le ministre vous avez
apporté des éléments de réponse
d'ailleurs ce matin peut-être
souhaiterez-vous les compléter lors de
ce débat en matière d'avancer sur la
façon dont sont traités les auteurs de
harcèlement dans les établissements
scolaires et puis peut-être qu'il
faudrait se pencher sur des méthodes
complémentaires certains pays sont en
avance sur ces sujets je pense au pays
scandinaves qui ont souvent un temps
d'avance sur ces considérations ils les
ont pris à bras le corps depuis
longtemps notamment des méthodes comme
la préoccupation partagée ou encore le
programme finlandais un programme qui
s'appelle qui va coulis qui est mis en
place en 2006 depuis 2006 donc ça fait
longtemps et qui est organisé autour de
discussion systématique de jeux de rôle
et c'est il y a une systématisation de
la hulute contre le harcèlement scolaire
dans tous les établissements en
finlandais il serait aussi bien de faire
un peu de parents gonage pour voir en
Europe notamment comment ont pu avancer
d'autres pays on le voit donc nous avons
beaucoup avancé sur la question du
harcèlement l'effet reste encore trop
grave et trop nombreux et je ne doute
pas qu'ensemble nous construirons des
nouveaux outils des nouvelles armes pour
lutter contre ce fléau merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre pour répliquer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur sénateur barjoton en effet le
programme PHARE que dont nous parlons à
une inspiration qui est qui est
finlandaise et lorsque j'ai évoqué les
la mesure et l'évaluation de ce
programme j'aurais dû mentionner le cas
de la Finlande où il a donné de bons
résultats je j'attire votre attention
sur le fait que ce programme a une
dimension pédagogique et ne vise pas
d'emblée à sanctionner il vise plutôt à
mener le le harceleur l'enfant harceleur
a reconnaître la gravité de ces actes et
à participer par la suite d'une
mobilisation de l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative à l'égard des faits
de harcèlement et en effet parfois on a
d'anciens harceleurs qui sont au premier
rang en quelque sorte des élèves
ambassadeurs pour se mobiliser contre
une situation de harcèlement et en ce
sens l'école maintient bien sa mission
première qui est une mission pédagogique
mais il faut reconnaître parfois que la
dimension pédagogique ne suffit pas que
la situation peut être si dégradée entre
des harceleurs ou un harceleurs et puis
les élèves harcelés que la séparation
entre les élèves devient la solution
ultime cela est possible dans le
secondaire bien sûr puisque les conseils
de discipline peuvent
scolariser un élève dans un autre
établissement que celui d'origine cela
n'était pas possible et n'est pas
possible dans le primaire puisqu'il n'y
a pas de conseil de discipline c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de passer par
une voie réglementaire et non pas par
une voie
législative par la voie de la loi de
manière à dans certains cas et en
dernier recours lorsque tout aura été
tout leur a été toutes les solutions
auront été envisagées de déplacer
l'élève par indépendamment de l'avis des
représentants légaux et selon une
procédure que je détaillerai si la
question m'est posée
je vous remercie la parole est à présent
à Madame Sabine egg pour le groupe
socialiste et vous avez trois minutes
chers collègues
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues cela a été dit près d'un
million d'élèves subissent chaque année
une forme de harcèlement durant leur
scolarité d'une violence parfois telle
qu'elle pousse certains enfants à tenter
à leurs jours il est intolérable
monsieur le ministre que les fondements
du vivre ensemble soient ainsi sapés et
que les jeunes soient éprouvés à l'âge
où ils font leur premier apprentissage
dévoilant leur fragilité propre à
l'adolescence
bien sûr il ne s'agit pas de dire ici
que rien ne se fait au sein de
l'éducation nationale même si le
programme PHARE c'est généralisé à la
rentrée 21 nous devons encore constater
la difficulté à franchir le mur de
l'administration scolaire et la
tentation du pas de vagues au sein de
certains étatsblissements la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire
passe aussi par les initiatives locales
associatives ou institutionnelle dans
mon département du Pas-de-Calais par
exemple j'ai animé avec les services de
l'État de la police de la gendarmerie de
la justice de l'éducation nationale
pardon une réunion visant à améliorer
l'accueil la protection le suivi des
élèves victimes de harcèlement scolaire
ainsi que la prise en charge des auteurs
de ces faits délictueux je me réjouis de
la mobilisation de tous ces acteurs bien
sûr mais cela reste encore insuffisant
et la question du harcèlement scolaire
révèle encore de grandes failles qui
doivent être comblées je viens donc de
déposer avec mes collègues sénateurs
socialistes d'une proposition de loi
visant à renforcer la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et le
cyber-harcèlement afin de compléter
l'arsenal et juridique existant notre
PPL se veut pragmatique simple et
concrète elle prévoit notamment
d'imposer aux réseaux sociaux une
nouvelle obligation de sensibilisation
des usagers de renforcer le poids des
adultes correctement formés sur le sujet
au sein de l'école que les auteurs
puissent être exclus au lieu de la
double peine qui s'impose aux victimes
forcées de quitter leur établissement
pour échapper à leurs bourreaux et je me
félicite monsieur le ministre que vous
ayez d'ores et déjà repris cette
disposition très importante en tout état
de cause la clé de tout c'est
l'augmentation du nombre d'adultes
effectivement présent dans les
établissements comme le réclame les
sénateurs de notre groupe à chaque
discussion budgétaire depuis maintenant
6 ans il est impératif monsieur le
ministre d'augmenter les postes de
personnel médico-sociaux de psychologue
dans les établissements scolaires
personnels qui jouent un rôle essentiel
dans la prévention la détection et la
prise en charge des cas de harcèlement
pour que la parole des enfants des
adolescents se libèrent ceux-ci doit se
sentir écouté compris protéger c'est par
la présence suffisante de personnes
formées et à l'écoute que nous pourrons
espérer le fléchissement de ce fléau
insupportable merci
merci chers collègues
monsieur le ministre pour réponses pour
deux minutes merci madame la présidente
madame la sénatrice van egg je vous
remercie d'abord pour le rapport et
votre travail sur le sujet que vous avez
réalisé avec madame la sénatrice
Melo je note au passage que votre
proposition de diffuser au mieux les
numéros 30 18 et 30 vins que nous avons
repris cette proposition lorsqu'elle
sera inscrite dans les carnets de
correspondance et surtout les
environnements numériques de travail il
y a une campagne d'affiches qui sont
déjà réalisées et que j'ai pu voir
presque systématiquement sur dans les
couloirs des établissements scolaires on
est plus à l'époque du pas de vague elle
évidence nous sommes très mobilisés sur
cette question on a passé un cap quand
même depuis un certain temps même s'il y
a du travail à faire à propos des élèves
harceleurs que nous allons éloigner je
veux ici remercier la sénatrice Mercier
de la proposition qu'elle a faite à
propos des élèves arceleurs nous
proposons donc de les éloigner
indépendamment de la vie des parents ou
des représentations ou des représentants
légaux lorsque la situation est devenue
intenable et lorsque la sécurité des
élèves harcelés en l'occurrence ou de
l'élève harcelé et mis en cause cela
suppose l'accord du maire de la commune
voire des deux mers s'il y a une
scolarisation dans une commune voisine
il faut procéder avec avec discernement
en la matière puisque nous avons à faire
à des enfants des enfants entre 6 et 11
ans que parfois les situations entre
harceleur et harcelés ne sont pas si
clair avec des échanges si j'ose dire
entre la situation des uns et des autres
mais il faut pouvoir envisager cette
possibilité lorsque la situation est
bloquée d'où le sens de la proposition
que j'ai faite
merci vous avez une minute pour
répliquer cher collègue
oui vous avez raison il faut agir avec
discernement monsieur le ministre mais
il faut pas disons facilité la vie au
harceleur au détriment du harcelé
merci la parole est à présent à Madame
Céline Brulin du groupe communiste vous
avez 5 minutes chers collègues
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègue le harcelement
le harcèlement scolaire est un fléau un
élève sur 10 subit chaque année une
forme de harcèlement ou de
cyber-harcèlement c'est un drame car il
entraîne des enfants vers des actes
extrêmes face à ces situations nous ne
sommes pas totalement démunies même s'il
n'existe pas de remède miracle le Sénat
a ainsi fait 35 propositions dans le
cadre d'une mission d'information qui a
été rappelée tout à l'heure la loi du 2
mars 2022 visant à combattre le
harcèlement scolaire a également donné
quelques outils il convient je crois
grâce à ce débat et je remercie la
collègue qu'il a initié d'en faire un
bilan afin de vérifier que les réponses
en matière de prévention de détection de
soutien aux victimes et à leur famille
sont opérants
la loi inscrit dans le code de
l'éducation la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire permettant de mieux
appréhender de punir ce phénomène dans
son article 1 il est instauré une
information sur les risques liés au
harcèlement scolaire délivrés chaque
année aux élèves et parents d'élèves
comment cela se traduit-il dans les
établissements scolaires avec quels
moyens son article 7 prévoit également
la remise d'un rapport relatif au frais
de consultation et de soins engagés par
les victimes monsieur le ministre ce
rapport a-t-il été produit pouvez-vous
nous en donner les éléments ce texte
prévoyait aussi la civilisation des
assistants d'éducation qui constituent
un des rouages d'alerte et de prévention
essentielle au sein des établissements
le décret a tardé à être pris et bien
qu'il soit désormais pris certaines
académies continuent visiblement de ne
pas appliquer cette disposition quand
est-ce que cette mesure sera généralisée
j'aimerais également rappeler la
conviction que j'ai plusieurs fois
supprimer ici d'une revalorisation du
statut des aesh qui leur garantiraient
entre autres une véritable formation
initiale et continue notamment en
matière de harcèlement le handicap
pouvant constituer un motif et j'y mets
évidemment beaucoup de guillemets autre
avancée de cette loi mais qui d'après
les remontées de terrain se révèle
encore insuffisantes le renforcement de
la formation et de la sensibilisation de
l'ensemble des personnels éducatifs quel
est le contenu de cette formation
initiale qu'en est-il pour la formation
continue le programme phare qui a été
évoqué à plusieurs reprises a été
généralisée vous l'avez dit vous-même
c'est une bonne chose sauf que en effet
sa généralisation a été lancée avant
même le retour d'expérience des six
académies tests or leur expertise
permettrait je crois d'améliorer ce
programme je pense par exemple la
constitution d'une équipe d'au moins
cinq personnes par collège ou par
circonscription pour le premier degré en
rappelant d'ailleurs que ce déploiement
je fais un moyen constant alors que les
personnels ont déjà de nombreuses
missions et on pourrait même dire de
plus en plus de missions à effectuer
avec les suppressions de poste risquent
de fragiliser ce travail-là aussi vous
évoquez régulièrement la baisse
démographique pour justifier ces
suppressions de poste mais la France
reste un mauvais élève au regard
d'autres pays européens en matière de
tout d'encadrement que se passe-t-il
quand un des membres de l'équipe n'est
plus en poste il faut alors recommencer
tout le processus ce qui est dommageable
même chose avec les 10 heures de
formation pour tous les élèves du CP à
la troisième qui les assure comment et
avec quels outils lors de votre audition
dans le cadre de la préparation du PLF
2023 nous vous rappelions et cela a été
fait aussi à l'instant la situation
critique de la médecine scolaire qui est
elle aussi un maillon essentiel de la
lutte contre le harcèlement c'est de
notoriété plus que publique les effectif
ont fondu comme neige au soleil encore
plus en milieu rural et nous manquons
également de psychologues pour les Raz
vous indiquez lors de cette audition de
voir rencontrer le ministre de la Santé
pour envisager une autre structuration
de la médecine scolaire et envisager des
alternatives qui permettraient de
répondre aux impératifs de médecine de
prévention et de détection quelles sont
ses alternatives où en est-on
aujourd'hui du travail que vous
proposiez d'initier enfin le harcèlement
scolaire a changé de dimension avec le
poids pris par les réseaux sociaux qui
n'offrent effectivement aucun répit aux
victimes les frontières de l'école sont
maintenant largement dépassés et il me
semble que les plateformes doivent
davantage assumer leur responsabilité
pourquoi ne pas avoir retenu l'idée
d'une contrainte pour les réseaux
sociaux de présenter régulièrement des
vidéos de prévention et de
sensibilisation au système au
cyber-harcèlement pardon
enfin je voudrais revenir sur ce que
vous avez dit ce matin sur le fait que
un enfant harceleur serait écarté plutôt
que la victime qui jusqu'à présent l'été
avez-vous consulté les associations
d'élus puisqu'en effet il faudrait
l'accord du maire dans l'école d'accueil
qu'il y a aussi je suis désolé de venir
sur ce sujet trivial mais des
conséquences financières puisqu'il y a
une participation de la commune dont
l'habitant l'enfant habitant doit aller
vers une autre école et je voudrais
savoir si vous avez pris le soin de
consulter les associations d'élus sur ce
point je vous remercie merci chers
collègues monsieur le ministre vous avez
deux minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice brûlin vous avez en effet
allusion au programme PHARE et à la loi
du 2 mars
2022 qui place la question de la
formation en leur cœur et de fait nous
avons
intensifié les programmes de formation
d'abord en les systématisant au niveau
des INP pour les professeurs stagiaires
ou pour les CPE stagiaires et puis nous
avons organisé séminaire nationaux et
avec des déclinaisons académiques pour
d'abord former les formateurs si je puis
dire afin que les choses se diffusent
ensuite au niveau des écoles et des
établissements c'est un processus lent
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de monde à
former sur le sujet cinq personnes par
établissement scolaires du côté du
secondaire cinq personnes par
circonscription
côté du primaire c'est un travail que
nous menons sur plusieurs années en
parallèle de cela il y a la
sensibilisation des familles c'est aussi
quelque chose d'important les familles
ont un rôle à jouer et donc en début
d'année scolaire nous insistons sur le
fait que les écoles et les
établissements doivent sensibiliser les
familles connaître les numéros 30 20 et
30 18 en particulier vous avez fait
allusion à la médecine scolaire j'en ai
parlé moi-même on attend le rapport des
trois inspections générales afin de
faire des propositions et je serai
heureux de venir en parler devant vous
si vous le souhaitez quant au plateforme
je suis en accord avec vous elle doivent
être responsabilisées c'est d'ailleurs
une réflexion et c'est d'ailleurs une un
échange que nous avons eu lors de la
visite opéré sur la plateforme 30 18
pardon le temps mais je reviendrai sur
la question des maires et des harceleurs
et des harceler je excusez-moi pour ce
retard je vous en prie monsieur le
ministre vous souhaitez répliquer
la parole est donc à présent à Monsieur
Jean Ingré du groupe Union centriste et
vous avez 8 minutes chers collègues
bien madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la communauté éducative et démunis
elle est démunie car elle est affaiblie
par un phénomène incompris de tous
pourtant bien présent le harcèlement
aujourd'hui le harcèlement scolaire
fracture notre jeunesse en deuil nos
familles et brise notre République
en s'attaquant à notre République aussi
dépassé que des armées le harcèlement
remet en question sa légitimité une
légitimité pourtant construite à travers
les siècles de Napoléon à Jules Ferry en
passant par Julie-Victoire Daubié
l'école républicaine de par sa capacité
à s'adapter aux circonstances parfois
aux crises a toujours su aller de
l'avant mais aujourd'hui cette
légitimité est menacée menacée par la
souffrance de millions d'élèves chers
collègues il est difficile de comprendre
la nature humaine la psychologie et les
rapports de force qui s'opèrent entre
les élèves
nous observons avec tristesse et colère
les conséquences funèses de ces abus
presque un million d'enfants un million
d'enfants subissent du harcèlement
scolaire en France en 2021 22 enfants
ont fait le choix de renoncer de
renoncer de la pire des manières vivant
une souffrance insupportable il ne se
sentait plus d'exister alors ils ont
fait le choix de ne plus souffrir
chers collègues nous constatons avec
regret la faible prise en charge notre
système éducatif à résoudre ce phénomène
difficilement sernables le harcèlement
prend plusieurs formes morales physiques
sexuelle et n'oublions pas le raquette
le harcèlement d'une manière générale
est un phénomène qui s'accroît et se
complexifie avec les réseaux sociaux le
semblant d'anonymat qu'il permet chez la
tendance à suivre les effets de meute et
la volonté de se distinguer du groupe
font des réseaux sociaux le lieu propice
et privilégié au harcèlement le
harcèlement scolaire est partout de
l'école à la maison en passant par les
transports en commun 50% des collégiens
se plaignent de la violence dans les
transports les effets de groupe ont
longuement été étudiés et font consensus
dans la communauté scientifique il y a
un leader des suiveurs des actifs et des
passifs ce sont ces mêmes passifs qui
parfois se trouvent au sein même du
corps enseignant corps enseignant censé
écouter et prendre des mesures qui
finissent par ne pas agir ou agir trop
tard
c'est l'un des principaux fléaux de
notre système éducatif les victimes de
harcèlement et leur famille sont parfois
confrontés à une parole qui est entendue
certes lorsqu'ils en ont la chance mais
qui n'est pas toujours considéré chers
collègues à quoi bon entendre lorsque
nous refusons d'écouter il est difficile
de reconnaître une situation un élève
est harcelé
le harceleur agit de façon cachée et les
formes que peut prendre le harcèlement
sont souvent interprétés comme de
simples chamailleries entre enfants les
adultes ne s'attardent pas toujours ou
pas assez sur certains phénomènes de
micro violence ils sont considérés comme
banal voire normaux entre jeunes ou
moins jeunes
nous assistons à une perte de confiance
de plus en plus grande entre les parents
les élèves et l'éducation nationale que
dire des délais de traitement trop long
au sein des établissements le délai doit
donc être définitivement et clairement
afin de ne pas laisser les familles et
les victimes en suspens pendant des mois
moi durant lesquels le harcèlement perdu
ou s'intensifie la prise en charge des
signalements au sein des établissements
reste floues les procédures de
signalement ne sont pas harmonisées à
certains égards elles sont même
inadaptées je le répète chers collègues
nous sommes en face d'un phénomène
profondément humain qui mérite une
réponse de l'État pourtant il faut
reconnaître les avancées en la matière
l'éducation nationale c'est dotée de
moyens considérables pour lutter contre
le harcèlement scolaire le programme
phare a le mérite d'exister il demeure
insuffisant ce programme rend les élèves
acteurs de la lutte contre le
harcèlement sur la base du volontariat
une procédure en apparence louable
monsieur le ministre il y a deux mois je
vous ai interpellé au du suicide du
petit Lucas suite à cette intervention
de famille de famille de mon département
dans les Vosges m'ont contacté pour
faire part d'une faille notoire faille
qui se transforme en cauchemar pour les
victimes les élèves harceleurs animés
par une soif de domination intègre le
programme PHARE programme qui pour
rappel est censé protéger les victimes
que se passe-t-il monsieur le ministre
il n'est plus question de prévention il
faut des réponses concrètes il est
nécessaire de responsabiliser des
établissements au harcèlement nous
devons faire de l'école un lieu de vivre
ensemble exemplaire la prise en charge
des victimes et fondamentales
prioritaire il faut en même temps
encadrer efficacement les harceleurs le
nombreuses méthodes existent pour
prendre en charge efficacement le
harcèlement je pense notamment à la
méthode Farsta no blame alproche et
Picasses monsieur le ministre j'ai cité
quelques méthodes quelle est votre
méthode je vous remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur ministre
vous avez deux minutes pour répliquer
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur engrais
il y a deux écueils au fond à éviter
dire que rien ne change dans l'éducation
nationale que
ce dont on parle n'est que du vent ou à
l'inverse bien sûr expliqué que le
programme PHARE que les dispositions qui
ont été prises ces dernières années
auraient tout changé miraculeusement
nous sommes sur un sur un chemin et je
reconnais avec humilité devant vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
nous avons du travail à réaliser du
travail à réaliser ensemble pour réduire
ce phénomène catastrophique qu'est le
harcèlement
premier point la formation des
enseignants et des adultes dans les
établissements et dans les écoles c'est
un point très important et comme je l'ai
indiqué ça prend du temps et bien
entendu compte contenu de la masse des
enseignants et des adultes mais
j'observe tout de même qu'il y a une
prise de conscience d'une manière
générale dans les communautés éducatives
prise de conscience qu'on observait pas
de la vie générale il y a quelques
années les délais de traitement sont
peut-être longs peut-être trop long
méfions-nous à l'inverse des procédures
expéditives il y a en la matière
possibilité par exemple pour les chefs
d'établissement ou pour les dazen de
procéder à des mesures de sauvegarde des
mesures par lesquelles on écarte
temporairement un élève harceleur sans
préjugés de la suite qui pourra être
donnée à la procédure et puis je
voudrais insister sur ce c'est que en
dépit de la démarche pédagogique qui est
celle du programme PHARE et qui est
essentiel j'insiste là-dessus il faut
également envisager des sanctions les
sanctions ça fait partie de la pédagogie
d'une manière générale que ce soit par
le biais des conseils de discipline ou
que ce soit par le biais du transfert de
l'élève de l'élève harceleur dans le
premier degré suite à une procédure que
nous voulons régler par la voie
réglementaire
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez une
minute pour répliquer chers collègues si
vous le souhaitez oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
j'entends vos propos sur le travail que
vous avez entamé notamment avec les
préconisations du Sénat c'est un travail
qui sera long vous venez de le dire
suite à l'interpellation que je vous
avais fait sur le suicide du petit Lucas
j'ai deux familles qui sont venus me
voir dans le département des Vosges la
dazen nous a aidé à aider les familles
comme vous venez de le dire je pense que
cette sensibilisation cette prise de
conscience de la part des familles suite
au travail que nous faisons de manière
collective doit aider mais si vous
voulez moi je suis toujours quand même
étonné qu'on puisse venir voir un
parlementaire pour des problèmes
internes à l'éducation nationale c'est
ça qui m'a un peu choqué depuis la
question que je vous avais posée
concernant le suicide du petit Lucas et
concernant les sanctions dans vos propos
conclusifs je suis tout à fait d'accord
je pense qu'il faut avoir des sanctions
accrues et j'ai presque envie de
reprendre la phrase d'un de vos
collègues ministres il faut être gentil
avec les gentils et méchants avec les
méchants je vous remercie merci la
parole est à présent à Madame Esther
benbassade du groupe n'est non inscrit
et vous avez trois minutes chers
collègues pour vous exprimer
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 7
janvier dernier Lucas
âgé seulement de 13 ans a mis fin à ses
jours si c'est si les causes directes de
son passage à la reste encore à
confirmer les conséquences du
harcèlement scolaire dont il a été
victime pendant des mois ne peuvent pas
être nié comme lui chaque année plus de
800 000 enfants souffrent de harcèlement
scolaire et 26% d'entre eux ont des
idées suicidaires
77% des jeunes déclarent avoir suivi des
violences à l'école qu'elle soit morale
ou physique les conséquences
psychologiques de ce que trop considère
comme de simples railleries subies
pendant l'enfance sont multiples perte
de l'estime de soi tendance dépressive
vulnérabilité relationnelle que ce soit
dans un contexte professionnel
ou amoureux un âge ou ses enfants
manquent encore de discernement ou et ou
très peu parviennent à parler de ce
qu'il subisse le soutien des services
scolaires et d'une nécessité évidente
comment t'expliquer l'escalade de
violence qu'a subi le petit Farès il y a
quelques semaines comment expliquer que
sa mère n'est pas même été prévenu par
la direction de l'établissement scolaire
il y a urgence à mettre en place des
protocoles adaptés afin de déceler au
plus tôt ces situations et d'éviter que
de nouveaux drames ne se produisent
mais il ne faut pas oublier que le
harcèlement scolaire ne commence pas et
ne cesse pas au port des écoles la rue
et les réseaux sociaux sont également le
lieu de calvaire pour des milliers de
jeunes sert des peines sont prévues pour
les auteurs du harcèlement scolaire mais
ses enfants en ont-ils seulement
conscients face à la hausse des cas le
programme phare des grilles d'évaluation
du danger un numéro d'écoute et d'être
sur le harcèlement sont-ils suffisants
les initiatives de certains
établissements et collectivités sont
louables à l'heure où la sensibilisation
des enfants doit être une priorité ces
violences ne doivent plus être ignorées
ni banalisé monsieur le ministre vous
assurez que la prévention et la lutte
contre le harcèlement entre l'élève et
l'une de vos priorités les enseignants
doivent plus que jamais être préparé
attentive les parents alertés afin que
l'école puisse redevenir un lieu
d'ouverture d'esprit dans lequel chaque
enfant quel qu'il soit puisse s'épanouir
sans entraxe je vous remercie merci
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice Benbassa un mot peut-être sur
les chiffres dont nous disposons qui ne
sont pas complètement stabilisés sur les
questions de harcèlement les mesures
varient selon les outils de mesure et
puis aussi selon la définition que l'on
donne au harcèlement à partir de combien
de situations
de violence
réelles physiques ou symbolique
d'insultes entre-t-on dans la catégorie
du harcèlement puisque le harcèlement
suppose des actes répétés à l'égard d'un
élève et donc là il y a une il y a un
peu de flou si vous voulez mais peu
importe la réalité est là et il faut
bien s'y attaquer déceler les situations
de harcèlement le plus rapidement
possible c'est évidemment un des
objectifs de notre mobilisation c'est un
des objectifs du programme PHARE
j'attire votre attention sur
l'importance des élèves des élèves
ambassadeurs comme nous les appelons qui
sont souvent les mieux à même de repérer
le changement de comportement par
exemple d'un de leurs camarades
changements de comportement alimentaire
un élève qui s'isole qui change dans son
attitude dans son rapport au travail
dans son rapport aux autres voilà des
signes qui peuvent laisser penser qu'une
situation de harcèlement et est en cours
et donc nous comptons beaucoup sur la
mobilisation des élèves et puis il faut
ensuite traiter ces situations
dans un premier temps quand la situation
est prise suffisamment tôt c'est dans le
cadre de l'établissement ou de l'école
que la situation peut être résolue dans
un deuxième temps il arrive malgré la
première tentative que la situation de
harcèlement perdure et à ce moment-là
les autorités académiques les autorités
départementales de l'éducation nationale
peuvent intervenir et
avec des psychologues ainsi que des
personnels de santé qui sont associés et
enfin dans un troisième temps dans les
cas extrêmes une sanction peut
intervenir selon les modalités que j'ai
précisé
merci Monsieur le Ministre Esther vous
avez une minute pour répliquer si vous
voulez chercher je voudrais aussi
attirer votre attention sur ce qu'on a
lu récemment à propos de violence
sexuelles à l'école entre des enfants de
6 ou 7 ans c'est quand même là aussi une
autre facette du même problème merci
merci cher collègue la parole est à
présent à notre collègue Monsieur
Bernard fieler du groupe RDSE et vous
avez 5 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
un an après la promulgation de la loi
visant à combattre le harcèlement
scolaire ou en sommes-nous
l'ajout de cette loi dans l'arsenal
législative visée à garantir au jeûnes
une scolarité apaisée elle visait d'une
part à mieux prévenir les actes de
harcèlement la prise en charge des
victimes et d'autre part en améliorer le
traitement judiciaire
prévenir les faits passe notamment par
une formation continue de toutes les
personnes qui entourent les élèves au
sein et en dehors des établissements sur
les sujets relatifs ou harcèlement je
salue le succès du programme PHARE rendu
obligatoire depuis la rentrée 2022 dans
les collèges et les écoles élémentaires
en plus de construire une communauté
protectrice autour des élèves d'associer
des instances démocratiques scolaires
telles que le comité d'éducation à la
santé et de mieux former les élèves à
raison de 10 heures par an le programme
mobilise aussi 10 élèves par
établissement en leur confiance le rôle
d'ambassadeur
cela responsabilise les élèves notamment
dans les établissements repérés plus et
permet aux victimes de se confier plus
facilement
je salue aussi la poursuite de la
Journée nationale de lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire se déroulant depuis
2015 chaque premier jeudi après les
vacances de la Toussaint elles
permettent sensibiliser les élèves par
des expositions et des manifestations
le Safer Internet Day fait sa vingtième
édition cette année et rassemble grâce
au travail de la Commission européenne
et de Internet sans crainte plus de 150
pays et de nombreuses associatifs
je salue également l'organisation des
campagnes vidéo ou des prix non au
harcèlement organisés dans de nombreux
établissements
s'ajoutent les numéros encore trop peu
connus vous l'avez dit à Monsieur le
Ministre et la plateforme digitale
dédiée à la lutte contre le harcèlement
qui a recensé plus de 170 déclarations à
ce jour
mais force est de constater que la
prévention ne suffit pas il faut prévoir
des solutions pour punir les faits
lorsque le harcèlement a été commis et
constaté
le nouveau cadre législatif et
réglementaire a permis de créer un délit
ouvrant la voie à des poursuites à
l'encontre de tout arceolor
un quantum de peine nécessaire
proportionné et adaptée à démontrer son
efficacité notamment dans les récentes
mises en garde à vue
le harcèlement scolaire ne passe plus
seulement par la parole ou la
maltraitance physique il sévit
dorénavant sur les réseaux sociaux qui
poursuivent la victime jusque chez elle
nos méthodes de sanction doivent
s'adapter la loi permis une avancée en
considérant ces derniers comme des
éléments constitutifs de cette nouvelle
infraction nous devons aller plus loin
il est temps d'intensifier et d'accès
notre réflexion sur les méthodes de
régulation des réseaux sociaux en
veillant à respecter le secret des
correspondances la liberté d'expression
et la sécurité pour nos enfants
il faut également que les victimes ne
subissent pas le préjudice du
déplacement secondaire scolaire alors
que les harceleurs conserveraient
bénéfices du maintien dans le même
établissement mais ce matin même
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez
peut-être rassuré dans ce domaine certes
les pouvoirs publics n'ont cessé depuis
2010 de ce mobiliser dans la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire il ne
serait toutefois se désengager
je regrette que les dernières études
disponibles remontent à 2021 nous ne
pouvons évaluer les premiers résultats
de cette loi promulguée l'an dernier
comme je regrette que le gouvernement
n'est pas remis comme annoncé dans un
délai de un an un rapport relatif à la
couverture des frais de consultation et
de soins engagés par les victimes ou par
les odeurs les auteurs des faits
en gardant un oeil sur les résultats
poursuivons le travail engagé notamment
dans le secteur du digital
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre vous avez deux minutes pour
répondre à notre collègue merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Sénateur
fialer vous avez raison à propos de
cette mobilisation annuelle ça compte
que ce soit le cefer Internet Day 6
février ou que ce soit au mois de
novembre chaque année la mobilisation
tour du prix non au harcèlement qui a un
vrai retentissement dans les
établissements scolaires j'ai pu le
mesurer moi-même vous avez également
raison je pense du côté des réseaux
sociaux nous devons les responsabiliser
la plateforme 30 18 est en lien avec les
principaux réseaux sociaux pour bloquer
des comptes avec des propos injurieux ou
des photographies qui n'ont pas à
circuler mais nous attendons que les
réseaux sociaux soient plus proactifs et
se mobilisent encore plus sur ces
questions
du côté des élèves harceleurs en effet
nous j'ai fait donc cette annonce
relative à une modification du code de
l'éducation donc une voie réglementaire
pour pouvoir
transférer des élèves harceleurs plutôt
que les élèves harcelés il est anormal
que ce soit les élèves harcelés qui
doivent quitter
un établissement par la force des choses
plutôt que les élèves harceleurs mais
nous insistons aussi sur le fait que
cette décision si elle doit intervenir
et en dépit de la vie donc des
représentants légaux des parents
n'intervient qu'en dernier recours
lorsque d'autres solutions auront été
épuisées mais je crois qu'il ne faut pas
l'écarter il s'agit moins d'une sanction
en réalité que d'une mise en sécurité
des élèves qui sont harcelés et dans une
situation où à l'évidence les procédures
de conciliation ne fonctionnent plus
merci vous avez une minute pour
répliquer chers collègues oui merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous répondez que vous attendez
beaucoup des réseaux sociaux qui se
régulent moi je pense qu'il faut pas
attendre passivement des réseaux sociaux
qui nous offre toutes les solutions à
ces risques de harcèlement je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit au contraire un
peu plus proactif et on attend justement
de l'autorité de l'État d'assurer cette
sécurité
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Madame Marie Mercier pour le
groupe les républicains et vous avez 4
minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues que se
passe-t-il donc dans nos cours d'école à
part jouer à son activité préférée
pourquoi parler de l'enfer des
récréations parce que dans ce petit
monde là secret et enfermé on y trouve
parfois du raquette des conflits de
l'intimidation mais aussi du harcèlement
un million à l'école ça fait un million
de famille ça fait combien de larmes la
victime vit un calvaire mais son
agresseur est en souffrance aussi
forcément tout le monde est perdant les
enfants les parents les familles les
enseignants et les chefs d'établissement
c'est compliqué le harcèlement toujours
c'est une violence répétitive fondée sur
des rapports de domination et de
discrimination d'âge de sexe de religion
qui a pour effet une dégradation des
conditions de vie de la victime qui se
sont de plus en plus isolés
détruites abandonné les conséquences du
harcèlement sont graves tant elles
portent atteinte à l'intégrité de ses
enfants elles peuvent parfois conduire
au pire il est urgent que le drame subit
par ses enfants soit rapidement admis et
sérieusement pris en considération sous
tous ces aspects en la matière la prise
en charge préventive est bien entendu la
meilleure des choses que le harcèlement
ne commence pas ou soit repéré et gérer
au plus tôt ce sont les programmes
phares mais quand il est trop tard et
installé c'est tout le monde adulte de
prendre toutes ses responsabilités
pleine et entière la victime doit être
protégée avoir foi en notre justice et
de son côté le harceleur doit réaliser
que ces actes sont répréhensibles et
être lui-même accompagné dans sa
souffrance sinon quel citoyen seront-ils
demain
la proposition de loi que j'ai déposé le
21 février visant dans le CADA
harcèlement scolaire à poser le principe
d'une mesure d'éloignement du harceleur
pour protéger la victime a pour revu de
poser un principe simple ce n'est pas la
victime de fuir de quitter
l'établissement et son environnement
pour échapper à son harceleur ce n'est
pas sa famille de s'adapter à ce
changement mais au petit harceleur les
mères me dis signer les dérogations avec
la boule au ventre disons c'est encore
ce gentil gamin qui va être obligé de
partir
j'ai voulu donner aux établissements
scolaires une référence sur laquelle
s'appuyait pour agir et je remercie mes
215 Collex sénateurs qui ont bien voulu
que signer mon texte et ceux qui le
partagent puisqu'ils ont repris il
existe bien sûr une procédure
disciplinaire applicable aux élèves qui
relèvent du pouvoir réglementaire et du
Règlement Intérieur des établissements
aujourd'hui rien n'empêche un conseil de
discipline d'exclure un élève auteur de
fait de harcèlement force et de
constater que la plupart de temps cela
ne se fait pas il s'agit donc bien des
fermiers de position de principe de
guider et de soutenir les établissements
dans leur prise de décision dans la
mesure de trop nombreux témoignages
montrent que les jeunes victimes
subissent la double peine
monsieur le ministre je me réjouis que
vous vous soyez en paix de cette idée
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir fait plus tôt
pour lutter efficacement contre la
scellement scolaire la nécessité reste
d'agir en amont en le reconnaissant en
le nom et en évaluant l'efficacité des
dispositifs mis en place
aucun enfant ne devrait avoir acquitté
une école protéger les enfants et notre
devoir comme celui de leur transmettre
des connaissances dans un milieu apaisé
qui leurlève
leur insouciance est-il leur laisse
leurs rêves
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la sénatrice Mercier pour votre
mobilisation sur cette question c'est
l'occasion pour moi de vous remercier
très vivement pour votre
proposition de loi qui a d'ailleurs été
signé sur tous les banques très
largement par
215 de vos collègues
en matière de d'enseignement primaires
comme vous le savez il n'y a pas de
procédure disciplinaire il n'y a pas de
conseil de discipline d'où l'impasse que
nous avons connu récemment dans le cas
du jeûne Maël puisque
le transfert ou le déplacement de
l'élève arceleur a été soumis à l'accord
des représentants locaux légaux à
l'accord de la famille avec la
proposition que je fais de modification
du code de l'éducation cela pourra
passer on pourra passer outre la vie des
parents avec
du maire concerné donc je pense que
c'est une avancée tout à fait importante
on inverse finalement la situation
puisque c'est le harceleur qui part et
non pas le harcelé il faut admettre que
c'est une question de justice tout
simplement et que on pourra avancer
quand il est trop tard comme vous l'avez
dit il faut pouvoir agir et pouvoir
déplacer l'élève harceleurs c'est une
solution de dernier recours mais il faut
pouvoir envisager cette solution dans le
premier degré comme dans le second degré
et donc c'est quelque chose que nous
allons faire et encore une fois je vous
remercie de votre mobilisation sur cette
question
merci
si vous le souhaitez répliquer merci
Monsieur le Ministre oui effectivement
vous proposez exactement en tout point
ce que je proposais de Nasri dans le
code de l'éducation je voudrais vous
prévenir de quelque chose j'ai fait de
nombreuses auditions et à l'intérieur
même de l'éducation nationale on m'a dit
ah bah si ça devient compliqué on écrira
plus jamais harcèlement on mettrait
autre chose je trouve que ça ce serait
pas digne
de l'éducation nationale
merci la parole est à présent monsieur
Yann chanterelle du groupe socialiste et
vous avez trois minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous avons
tous et tout était profondément touché
par le suicide du jeune Lucas qui
subissait quotidiennement harcèlement et
moqueries sur son orientation sexuelle
depuis ce drame quelles sont les mesures
que vous avez prises pour mettre fin aux
brimad quotidienne sur subit par une
partie de nos enfants votre volonté
d'éradiquer ce fléau que constitue le
harcèlement scolaire se vérifiera par
vos actions sur deux leviers essentiels
plus de moyens humains à l'école et un
changement de la culture scolaire qui
prévaut dans notre pays chacun le sait
la meilleure façon de lutter contre le
harcèlement scolaire c'est d'augmenter
la présence en personnel pour encadrer
les élèves toutes les recherches
démontrent que plus les effectifs sont
réduits dans l'établissement et dans la
classe plus le harcèlement diminue or la
France a les classes les plus chargé de
l'Union européenne au collège l'effectif
moyen approche 26 élèves c'est très
au-dessus de la moyenne européenne
située sous la barre des 21 plus d'une
classe sur 10 dépasse désormais les 30
élèves ces deux fois plus qu'il y a 10
ans et pourtant depuis son arrivée au
pouvoir Emmanuel Macron n'a fait
qu'empirer cette situation dramatique
depuis 2018 le second degré a perdu
9322 enseignants et la saignée continue
puisque votre ministère annonce de
nouvelles suppressions de poste pour la
rentrée 2023 à ce terrible bilan
s'ajoute l'abandon de la médecine
scolaire qui a déjà été évoquée par des
collègues la France compte aujourd'hui
un psychologue de l'éducation nationale
pour 1500 élèves et un médecin scolaire
pour
16686 élèves loin très loin de la
préconisation de votre ministère de 1
pour 5000 comment prétendre lutter
contre le harcèlement en colère quand on
réduit à ce point les moyens de l'école
le second levier c'est celui de la
culture et de l'organisation scolaire
qui prévale dans notre pays face au
fléau du harcèlement la manière dont on
conçoit et organise l'école peut le
favoriser ou le décourager on a trop
tendance à prendre le problème sous
l'angle de la discipline avec une
approche purement punitive et à déléguer
la lutte contre le harcèlement au CPE
plutôt que de développer une approche
collective c'est en amont dans notre
culture et organisation scolaire qu'il
faut aller chercher les ressources pour
lutter contre le harcèlement face à une
école de la concurrence entre individu
du classement et de la distinction qui
crée des rivalités contre la pression
des notes et le stress des examens
défendons un modèle qui prône des
valeurs de solidarité de coopération de
bienveillance de tolérance et
d'inclusion un modèle aussi où la santé
mentale n'est plus un tabou un modèle
scolaire qui place la mixité en son cœur
pour développer une approche positive de
l'autre ou l'altérité la différence ne
constitue pas un danger mais une chance
pour aller dans ce sens vous nous aviez
justement promis ici même monsieur le
ministre des annonces sur la mycité
scolaire pour le 20 mars nous les
attendons toujours où en est-on merci
monsieur le ministre pour répondre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur chanterelle depuis
la catastrophe la mort du jeune Lucas
nous avons intensifié en particulier les
programmes de lutte contre les haines
anti LGBT j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler
nous préparons activement la journée du
17 mai et nous avons généralisé les
observatoires qui sont des bons points
d'appui dans chaque académie pour se
mobiliser pour sensibiliser au N anti
LGBT qui ont des effets catastrophiques
dans nos écoles vous avez mentionné la
question des effectifs et là je suis
obligé d'apporter un bémol à votre
propos il n'y a pas de lien si évident
que cela entre les situations de
harcèlement et puis les effectifs dans
le cas du jeune Maël par exemple la
classe la classe qui était qui est la
sienne n'a que dit élèves et donc on est
dans une situation qui n'est pas une
situation de surcharge en ce qui
concerne la médecine scolaire bien
entendu que je partage le constat je
l'ai dit mais nous avons des postes qui
ne sont pas pourvus j'ai en mémoire la
situation du département des Vosges
qui a 10 postes de médecins scolaires et
sur ces 10 postes 8 ne sont pas pourvus
8 sont vacants et donc on pourrait en
rajouter
5 ou 6 que ça ne changerait rien à la
situation et donc on a un problème de
fond qui est celui du qui vient du fait
que les étudiants en médecine ne
choisissent pas la médecine scolaire ne
choisissent pas non plus la médecine du
travail donc c'est une réflexion de fond
sur l'organisation de la médecine
scolaire et sur ces liens avec la
médecine de ville qui est en jeu enfin
je souscris bien sûr à l'approche
collective que vous soulignez c'est la
formation de tous les adultes pas
seulement la vie scolaire mais également
les professeurs mais également toutes
celles et ceux qui interviennent auprès
des élèves qui peut faire fonctionner et
qui fait fonctionner le dispositif phare
merci la parole vous souhaitez répliquer
la parole est à présent à madame
Béatrice Gosselin du groupe les
républicains et vous avez quatre minutes
chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues en France et cela est
déjà été évoqué près d'un enfant sur 10
serait victime de harcèlement dans son
établissement scolaire et ces dernières
années le harcèlement en ligne est venu
amplifier ce phénomène en 2021 ce sont
20 enfants et adolescents qui ont perdu
la vie à cause de ce fléau on considère
qu'il y a harcèlement scolaire quand un
jeune est victime d'une agression
répétée délibérée souvent effectués en
meute c'est également un rapport de
force et de domination entre 1 ou
plusieurs élèves et une ou plusieurs
victimes le caractère répétitif des
agressions crée souvent un sentiment
d'isolement et d'abandon des harceler
qui deviennent incapables de trouver des
réponses pour s'en sortir
le harcèlement pénalise durablement le
parcours scolaire de la jeune victime et
peut entraîner des conséquences
psychologiques très lourdes allant
jusqu'au drame du décrochage scolaire à
des conduites autodestructrices voire
suicidaires dans un monde où Internet à
Copar nos vies et plus encore celle de
nos adolescents le harcèlement en ligne
ou cyber-harcèlement sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les forums les jeux vidéos
multiformes ou sur un blog est devenu un
le véritable danger
c'est le type de harcèlement qui est le
plus destructeur pour les victimes car
via les réseaux sociaux les agressions
ou brimades peuvent frapper leur victime
à tout moment de la journée de la nuit
et quel que soit l'endroit où elle se
trouve de plus le harceleur peut se
servir d'un pseudo et ne pas dévoiler
son identité alors quelle mesure pour
lutter efficacement contre la
cyber-harcèlement et ainsi casser cette
spirale de violence le comité
d'éducation à la santé à la citoyenneté
et à l'environnement le CESCE a commencé
à sensibiliser les chefs d'établissement
à ses problèmes de harcèlement cependant
ce dernier montre ses limites avec
beaucoup de dispositifs listés les un
manque de moyens humains et financiers
pour les appliquer depuis la rentrée
2022 le ministre d'éducation nationale
que vous êtes arrêté un plan de
prévention du harcèlement entre élèves
avec le programme PHARE dont vous avez
déjà parlé devenu obligatoire dans nos
établissements
celui-ci combine plusieurs actions et
dispositifs incluant un large éventail
d'outils variés et concrets se basant
sur 8 piliers pour notamment éduquer
pour prévenir des problèmes de
harcèlement former une communauté
protectrice de professionnels intervenir
efficacement sur les situations de
harcèlement pour une réussite de ce
dispositif il faut impliquer élève et
personnel travailler en collaboration
avec les parents et les partenaires
associatifs mettre à disposition une
plateforme numérique dédiée et créer une
équipe de cinq personnels formés et une
équipe d'élèves d'ambassadeurs on y va
académique deux superviseurs sont des
personnes ressources pour les
établissements et sur le plan national
les deux lignes dont vous parliez le 30
20 le 30 18 qui propose un soutien aux
victimes de harcèlement
les responsables des établissements
scolaires doivent être vigilants à
détecter tout harcèlement mais il est
également indispensable que les
harceleurs prennent conscience de leurs
actes et des conséquences judiciaires et
financières qu'ils en cours ou leurs
parents lorsqu'ils sont mineurs cette
année notre collègue Marie Mercier
déposait une proposition de loi visant à
poser le principe de l'éloignement du
harceleur pour protéger la victime et
c'est une très bonne chose enfin
j'évoquerai pour ma part plusieurs
pistes de réflexion et d'action qui
pourraient être mises en place le
renforcement du programme PHARE avec la
Proformation continue du groupe des cinq
personnes de l'établissement secondaire
ou par circonscription pour le primaire
une obligation des plateformes de
contrôler de supprimer les conflits les
contenus délictueux qu'ils soient
d'ordre sexuel ou de harcèlement
l'exclusion automatique du harceleur de
l'établissement lorsque la situation de
harcèlement est avérée
et le développement de la médecine dont
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure avec des
professionnels qui soient formés à
détecter le mal-être d'une victime de
harcèlement et je sais vous l'avez dit
que le mur de médical vous avez du mal à
trouver des médecins pour le la
prévention scolaire mais la prévention
par l'information est également est
primordiale et je crois que dénoncer un
comportement délictueux de harcèlement
doit être voir pour tous je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice Gosselin je suis je partage
vos propos bien entendu dans dans les
différentes déclinaisons de la
mobilisation que nous menons et j'ai
déjà indiqué à quel point nous sommes
sur le chemin rien n'est complètement
réalisé mais nous avançons et nous
progression par exemple en matière de
cyber-harcèlement avec le 30 18 les les
plateformes réagissent rapidement en
réalité on arrive à bloquer les
photographies ou des propos en quelques
heures de manière à ce que les élèves
concernés soient
protégés j'ai pu écouter lors d'une
visite au 30 18 des conversations entre
des collégiens ou des familles qui
appellent paniquer parce que il y a tel
ou telle photo qui circule et puis les
personnes qui répondent il y a des
techniciens il y a des psychologues on
prend en charge les élèves et je salue
évidemment le travail qui est réalisé en
la matière je voudrais aussi mentionner
un point qui complète votre propos dans
la généralisation du programme PHARE on
est à 60 % il y a 86% on n'est pas du
tout à 100% mais tout de même ça
progresse le fait que ce programme donc
sera étendu au lycée à partir de la
rentrée prochaine en sachant que les cas
de harcèlement du côté des lycées sont
moins nombreux c'est plutôt du côté du
cycle 3 et du collège que les situations
de harcèlement sont les plus nombreuses
mais il n'y a aucune raison de ne pas
non plus se mobiliser du côté des lycées
et c'est ce que nous allons faire pour
le dire plus rapidement
l'éducation nationale se met en marche
et se met en mobilisation parfois
comparé à une grosse bête de l'air
glaciaire moi je vois que l'éducation
elle s'est bouger sur des questions
importantes comme celle du harcèlement
merci
vous avez une minute pour répliquer
chers collègues oui je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre pour toutes ces
informations il est vrai que l'éducation
nationale bouge et doit bouger encore
parce que je crois que aucun enfant doit
souffrir de harcèlement mais il me
semble aussi que sur l'ensemble des
réseaux des médias nous devons continuer
à faire des des spots pour expliquer ce
que les ce qu'est le harcèlement parce
que certains enfants quand ils sont
petits sans doute moins qu'en vrai quand
ils sont grands ne savent pas que leur
gestes ou leurs paroles peuvent être de
faire partie de ce harcèlement et il y a
que la formation l'information qui doit
passer et que les parents comme les
enseignants comme toute personne doit
défendre prendre qu'il n'y ait plus
jamais d'enfants harcelés merci merci la
parole est à présent à notre collègue
madame Sylvie Robert du groupe
socialiste et vous avez trois minutes
chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme le
rapport d'information sénatoriale sur le
harcèlement et le cyber-harcèlement de
2021 l'avait démontré ce phénomène
violent n'a été appréhendé reconnu que
tardivement en France alors même que des
travaux de chercheurs avec commencer dès
les années 70 pour autant avec le
développement du numérique et
l'explosion de l'usage des réseaux
sociaux ces formes ont évolué alors
cantonais à l'enceinte de l'école le
harcèlement scolaire se prolonge
désormais sur les plateformes numériques
l'amplifiant dramatiquement et le
rendant plus sauvage et potentiellement
dangereux d'ailleurs 2009 Michel
Vallerey dans ce rapport sur le
cyber-harcèlement soulignait le rôle
joué par l'anonymisation et il a fait
même que le cyber-harcèlement justement
par ses caractéristiques et son objet
pouvaient avoir des effets
particulièrement dangereux et durable
ainsi la loi du 2 mars 2022 visant à
combattre le harcèlement scolaire a été
une première étape elle a notamment
assigné au fournisseur d'accès Internet
la lutte contre harcèlement scolaire
comme objectif et à établir une
obligation de modération des contenus de
même nature sur les réseaux sociaux
néanmoins il apparait souhaitable et
pertinent d'aller plus loin dans cette
régulation par les plateformes même si
cette dernière ne sont pas responsables
des faits de harcèlement mais constitue
plutôt des vecteurs par lesquels le
harcèlement ce matérielise sur ce point
le rapport précité effectue une série de
préconisations tout en rappelant la
difficulté du cadre juridique national
et européen parmi ces propositions
figuraient l'obligation par exemple pour
les réseaux sociaux de présenter de
manière explicite et compréhensible par
les jeunes utilisateurs des extraits des
principales conditions d'utilisation
singulièrement c'est le relatives au
cyber-harcèlement l'obligation pour les
réseaux sociaux de présenter
périodiquement à leurs utilisateurs une
courte vidéo de sensibilisation sur les
bons usages du numérique sur la
prévention du cyber-harcèlement et les
moyens pour les victimes de réagir
sur cette seconde recommandation à
consensus semble émerger suite à
l'adoption du digital service actes au
niveau européen lesquels renforcent la
responsabilité des plateformes
d'ailleurs marcoleg Sabine van egg a
déposé une proposition de loi dans ce
sens celle-ci est au frais utilement
notre arsenal juridique législatif et
compléterait habilement la proposition
de loi visant à instaurer une majorité
numérique à lutter contre la haine en
ligne qui je crois va être prochainement
débattu dans notre hémicycle ainsi
monsieur le ministre vous qui êtes
engagé sensible à la gravité du
cyber-harcèlement y seriez-vous
favorable je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice Robert je vous remercie
également pour vos propos qui témoignent
de la mobilisation du Sénat tout entier
finalement sur cette question et je suis
tout entier avec vous sur cette question
aussi à propos du cyber-harcèlement j'ai
mentionné la plateforme 38 j'ai
mentionné la responsabilité des
plateformes je suis tout à fait ouvert
et disposé à avancer sur cette question
bien entendu que l'État a une
responsabilité en la matière et donc je
suis ouvert au travail commun avec avec
vous pour avancer progresser et réduire
le fléau du cyber-harcèlement
merci
lapin à madame vous vouliez répliquer
pardon les non non mon cher collègue
allez-y
non je voulais remercier Monsieur le
Ministre de sa réponse je pense qu'on a
beaucoup de travaux à venir dans le dans
le domaine du cyber-harcèlement et
singulièrement même dans le domaine du
numérique et je pense que ce sera une
responsabilité collective de pouvoir
avancer ensemble effectivement merci
beaucoup merci la parole est à présent à
notre collègue madame Sabine Drexler
pour le groupe les républicains et vous
avez trois minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues la
médiatisation récente de plusieurs
suicides d'enfants a révélé à ceux qui
l'ignoraient encore ce qui était le
harcèlement scolaire et ses effets à
court terme
ce que l'on sait moins c'est que la
santé leur travail plus tard ou la
parentalité de ceux qui auront subi fait
subir ou étaient témoins de ces
violences en se remarqué toute leur vie
anxiété sociale pour les victimes abus
de pouvoir au travail ou en famille pour
les agresseurs sentiments d'impuissance
pour les témoins le harcèlement scolaire
explique de nombreux mots à l'âge adulte
dépression
violence intra familiale chômage ses
conséquences sanitaires humaines et
financières sont énormes pour la société
l'éducation nationale a pris conscience
de la nécessité d'agir mais il me semble
il semble à l'enseignant spécialisée que
j'ai été que la mise en place de
programmes tels que phares ne peut être
efficace qu'à la condition que des
personnels des professionnels dédiés
soient présents en appui des enseignants
et auprès des élèves pour bien connaître
et suivre les situations individuelles
sans moyens humains ces dispositifs
resteront des coquilles vides des
méthodologies pour la plupart théorique
souvent impossible à mettre en oeuvre
faut d'équipe spécialisée pour les
accompagner
malheureusement vous le savez monsieur
le ministre les écoles en zone
prioritaire bénéficient de moyens encore
conséquents mais dans la ruralité les
postes spécialisés sont supprimés les
uns après les autres plus de médecine
scolaire plus de psychologues plus
d'enseignants spécialisés quasiment
partout ceux qui restent sont submergés
peu reconnus pour ce qu'ils font dans
l'impossibilité de remplir leur mission
et de répondre à la masse des demandes
d'aide
je pense qu'il s'agit là d'un mauvais
calcul car ces économies à court terme
auront ont déjà des conséquences
humaines et sociales désastreuses je le
vois chez moi en pleine campagne où les
enseignants sont livrés à eux-mêmes et
où les violences intrafamiliales
explosent monsieur le ministre je vous
pose la question vaut-il mieux prévenir
ou guérir vaut-il mieux créer des postes
d'enseignants spécialisés ou des postes
d'intervenants sociaux en gendarmerie on
nous dit que la France compte
suffisamment d'enseignants peut-être
mais il ne faut pas négliger la ruralité
ne pas négliger des territoires que le
pense préservé et qui ne le sont en fait
plus du tout
chez moi dans le sud de l'Alsace il ne
reste que trois personnels spécialisés
pour 108 communes les enseignants les
élus et les familles se sentent
abandonnés et je crains qu'il n'ait
raison
merci monsieur le ministre pour répondre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice Draxler non ils ne sont pas
abandonnés ça c'est quelque chose que je
peux vous assurer d'abord parce que et
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler devant
vos collègues nous avons lancé un plan
ruralité avec un engagement plurianuel à
partir de cet automne pour donner de la
visibilité en matière de poste sur trois
ans pour ceux qui concerne les écoles
dans les territoires ruraux donc nous
allons
offrir cette cette visibilité au maire
pour éviter d'une année sur l'autre des
changements brutaux de la carte scolaire
par ailleurs en matière de moyens
humains les zones les territoires ruraux
sont relativement favorisés par rapport
au territoire
urbain et c'est une bonne chose bien
entendu puisque la question de
éloignement fait que la densité des
écoles est moindres et donc nous avons
un taux d'encadrement qui est meilleur
dans les territoires ruraux que dans les
territoires
urbains mais cela ne répond pas
entièrement à votre question sur le
harcèlement nous avons des moyens et des
moyens par exemple en matière de
formation La formation que ce soit au
niveau national au niveau académique ou
au niveau départemental ça coûte ça
représente des moyens et nous sommes
évidemment déterminés à faire de telle
sorte que ces moyens soient prorogés
parce que nous devons réduire à
l'évidence et de manière absolument
déterminante les situations de
harcèlement encore une fois nous sommes
sur un chemin il est territoires ruraux
ne sont pas oubliés
merci vous pouvez répliquer une minute
chaque collègue
monsieur le ministre dans certains
secteurs en France il n'y a même plus de
psychologues scolaire pour pour évaluer
les élèves en situation pour lesquels il
y a une suspicion de handicap il y a
plus d'enseignants spécialisés pour
attraper des enfants qui seraient
pourtant rattrapables quel gâchis et
quel coup aussi à venir dans quelques
années pour accompagner les adultes qui
seront devenus et qui seront dans
l'incapacité de s'insérer dans la
société des coûts qui seront et qui
seront déjà autrement plus élevés que
les quelques postes économisés
merci la parole est à présent à Madame
Toine bourrin pour le groupe les
républicains et vous avez trois minutes
chaque colonne
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
le harcèlement scolaire blesse broie
brise et vole ce que la vie offre de
plus précieux l'enfance ce terreau
fertile ou pousse les goûts
l'apprentissage et les prémices de la
conscience morale si vite et donc social
dans ce pays où l'on prétend combattre
l'endémie d'Amal par un numéro vert il
est temps de mettre un coup d'arrêt à
une spirale que le développement des
technologies rend bien souvent infernal
pour y parvenir monsieur le ministre
c'est une culture de la vigilance qu'il
nous faut instituer une culture qui se
pense et se déploie au plus près du
terrain c'est-à-dire des victimes
potentielles ou avérées il s'agit de
détecter rapidement d'agir en local pour
laisser les enfants le moins longtemps
possible en situation de harcèlement car
les premiers témoins sont les enfants
eux-mêmes ils sont spectateurs libérons
leurs paroles expliquons que l'idée
n'est pas de dénoncer un harceleur mais
de signaler un élève harcelé c'est une
assistance à personne en danger à cet
égard les applications intracollège et
lycées type Pronote pourrait être
utilisé comme plateforme interne
d'alerte permettant aux témoin de
signaler un élève en difficulté tout en
préservant leur anonymat
premier rempart dans l'accompagnement
psychosocial nous devons également
redresser une médecine scolaire en grand
danger oui je le répète une médecine
scolaire abandonnée nous comptons
seulement un médecin pour 12000 élèves
une situation que Dominique Bussereau
qualifiait d'indigence devant le Sénat
lors de sa dernière audition
plus encore il convient de traiter ce
fléau dans son intégralité le programme
PHARE dont vous avez annoncé le
déploiement au lycée n'est qu'une
réponse partielle à un problème global
ce qu'il nous faut comme en Finlande
depuis plusieurs générations c'est un
bouleversement culturel l'avènement
d'une société de grand témoin non de la
suspicion mais de l'attention portée aux
autres ou chacun est le maillon d'une
chaîne de valeur trop souvent
ignorée chez nous le respect de l'autre
l'interaction sociale et la
compréhension des émotions d'autrui plus
qu'un programme la Finlande a développé
cette culture de la vigilance que le
temps long et surtout les moyens humains
comme financiers font infuser au
quotidien avec des résultats surprenants
marqués par la baisse de plus de 40% du
phénomène enfin comment peut-on penser
lutter contre le harcèlement scolaire en
faisant l'économie de son volet cyber
nous avons le devoir d'éviter la
dissémination des contes multiplication
d'identité des identités factices et des
comptes fantômes qui prospèrent grâce à
l'anonymat et aux pseudonymat
qu'attendons-nous pour corréler
l'identité numérique à l'identité réelle
des utilisateurs de réseaux sociaux
techniquement c'est déjà possible alors
Monsieur le Ministre les militaires qui
savent mieux que personne traiter
l'urgence ont une formule que je fais
mienne être à l'heure c'est déjà être en
retard du retard nous en avons à
rattraper la France le peut comme la
Finlande l'a fait merci chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la sénatrice bourra évidemment je
partage vos préoccupations sur les
questions de cyber-harcèlement
permettez-moi un mot sur le cas de la
Finlande que vous avez cité justement
dans le cas de la Finlande le programme
qui va qui a donné de bons résultats
à midi 10 ans pour parvenir aux
résultats que l'on que l'on sait donc ça
a pris du temps aussi en Finlande quant
au programme que nous avons déployé il
est beaucoup plus récent bien entendu
nous espérons avoir des résultats plus
rapidement en évaluation internationale
en tout cas les regards internationaux
qui sont portés sur nos efforts salut la
qualité de ce que nous faisons on a un
problème plutôt encore de déploiement je
dirais on n'est pas à 100% loin de là
mais les efforts que nous faisons sont
salués il nous espérons mettre moins de
10 ans pour parvenir à des résultats
comparables à ceux de la Finlande
l'expérience internationale est
évidemment très
utile pour ceux qui concerne
ce que nous faisons du côté des écoles
des collèges et des lycées
merci si vous souhaitez répliquer une
minute
juste une petite précision une petite
ministre c'est que les résultats du
programme Finlandais sont bien meilleurs
que les 40% que j'évoquais au bout de 10
ans les 40% que j'ai évoquais ce sont
des résultats qui ont été chiffrés
évalués au bout de deux voire trois ans
merci monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
vous avez 5 minutes pour vous exprimer
si vous le souhaitez maintenant
merci madame la Présidente je vais
m'exprimer brièvement car je pense que
nous avons
non pas fait le tour de cette question
comment pourrions-nous mais enfin
aborder un certain nombre de questions
importantes je me permettrai simplement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
récapituler quelques points d'abord la
question de la formation puisque ce
cette question est revenue à plusieurs
reprises nous avons concentré nos
efforts sur les équipes au sein des
écoles et des collèges et notre objectif
effectivement celui de former tous les
personnels comme le prévoit d'ailleurs
la loi du 2 mars 2022 a commencé par la
formation systématique des professeurs
stagiaires qui a commencé nous allons
donc mobiliser encore davantage les
innsp et les écoles académiques de
formation continue nous devons aussi
suivre qualitativement et quantitivement
les actions menées et j'ai indiqué que
nous avons encore des marges de
progression puisque 86% des collèges et
60% des écoles sont actuellement
inscrits dans le programme l'objectif
c'est évidemment 100% et l'extension du
programme
au lycée dès la rentrée prochaine
comme le recommande les sénatrice mélo
et vanneg dans leur rapport
d'information de septembre 2001 nous
allons mettre en place la
systématisation à chaque rentrée
scolaire de la communication des numéros
d'urgence le 30 18 et le 30/20 dans les
carnets de correspondance et les
supports numériques enfin à propos de la
situation de l'élève harceleur
le rôle si le rôle de l'Éducation
nationale est de prévenir d'accompagner
et de protéger les élèves il faut le
reconnaître certaines situations ne
peuvent se régler qu'en séparant les
élèves harcelés de leur harceleur
souvent pour mettre fin rapidement ou
souffrance causées par le harcèlement
les parents de l'élève harcelé font le
choix de le changer d'établissement et
je comprends nous comprenons le
sentiment d'injustice qui peut naître de
cette situation puisqu'il n'est pas
possible dans le premier degré
contrairement au second degré qui
dispose d'un conseil de discipline de
déplacer un élève dans une autre école
sans l'accord des parents et bien nous
mettons en place des actions éducatives
en fonction de la gravité de la
situation y compris donc dans les cas
extrêmes lorsqu'un élève fait peser du
fait de son comportement répété une
menace grave sur la sécurité des autres
élèves et bien nous allons porter une
évolution des textes réglementaires pour
instaurer une procédure permettant de
déplacer dans une autre école un élève
auteur de harcèle de harcèlement et ceci
sans l'accord des représentants légaux
c'est l'obligation de mise en sécurité
de l'élève qui justifie cette exception
bien entendu nous avons affaire à des
élèves de 6 à 10 ans donc nous devons
être prudents car nombre de cas de
harcèlement ne sont pas aussi simple
qu'il n'y paraît mais le déplacement de
l'élève harceleur et tout de même
essentiel même si toute procédure
d'exclusion doit être entourée des
garanties indispensables aux droits de
l'enfant qu'il soit l'élève harcelé ou
l'élève harceleur si vous me permettez
je terminerai mes propos en ayant une
pensée
émue pour tous les élèves victimes de
harcèlement scolaire notre débat je
crois leur rampe hommage et je sais que
nous sommes tous ici pleinement engagés
pour trouver des solutions afin de
prévenir ce phénomène et les drames
encore récents qui viennent nous
rappeler douloureusement qu'il nous
reste encore à faire je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre pour conclure
le débat la parole est à Monsieur Max
Brisson pour le groupe des Républicains
[Applaudissements]
d'abord merci monsieur le ministre pour
vos propos de fin et merci d'ailleurs
pour toutes les précisions et les
annonces qui ont nourris cet échange je
crois que le groupe est républicains a
eu raison de demander ce débat il a
généré du bien compréhensible
consensus cela risque de ne pas être
tout à fait le cas dans le débat qui va
suivre donc nous avons goûté et je pense
que le sujet le mérité je remercie
Alexandra borchio fontaine d'avoir posé
fortement tout à l'heure les termes du
débat et d'avoir largement repris comme
beaucoup d'entre vous les travaux de la
Haute Assemblée notamment à la à
l'occasion de la mission des formations
de nos collègues Sabine Vaneck et
Colette mélo plusieurs drames sont des
lavenus rappelés récemment l'urgence
intensifier la lutte contre ce fléau
beaucoup ont parlé de Lucas
qui s'est suicidé après avoir été
harcelé dans son collège et sur les
réseaux sociaux en raison de son
homosexualité je voudrais rappeler moi
ce lycéen qui après avoir subi un
orcèlement dans son ancien collège à
assassiné récemment son enseignante dans
son nouveau lycée il est hasardeux bien
sûr de faire la moindre corrélation mais
le drame sergent de Luz est dans toutes
les têtes beaucoup ont dit
qu'au-delà de ces cas extrêmes qui
émaillent l'actualité qui a aussi une
réalité ordinaire quotidienne vécue par
de nombreux enfants beaucoup ont
justement rappelé que le
cyber-harcèlement prolonge dans la
sphère privée y compris le week-end le
harcèlement et que depuis le confinement
les cas sont de plus en plus nombreux
pour autant
comme l'indiqué déjà notre mission
sénatoriale nous manquons d'appareils
statistiques d'enquête précise récente
et régulière par ailleurs il faudra
aussi que nous menions assez rapidement
une évaluation des effets du programme
PHARE ainsi que du dispositif pénal
issu de la loi du 2 mars 2022 il s'agit
d'un préalable essentiel pour un plan
d'action plus efficace en 2021 notre
mission pointée la détection comme un
axe majeur
pour progresser nous avons beaucoup
parlé de besoins de formation des
personnels le premier niveau de lutte
contre le harcèlement passe à défait par
la compréhension du phénomène et la
communication le principe d'une
formation initiale et continue de
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés a été
inscrit dans la loi du 2 mars 2022 mais
semble loin d'être appliqué dans les
faits vous venez de le dire et vous
venez de réagir sur le sujet deux tiers
des enseignants dénonçant encore un
manque de formation ainsi qu'une absence
de prise en considération par leur
hiérarchie vous avez réagi tout à
l'heure sur le padvag accepter cependant
que le sujet dérange toujours et
malheureusement il n'est pas c'est
parfois encore parfois encore l'inertie
qui prévaut beaucoup l'ont dit avec un
temps plus ou moins conciliant il est
nécessaire d'identifier plus rapidement
les cas de harcèlement nous butons ici
sur le manque criant de médecins
scolaire d'infirmières de psychologue
pourtant les mieux à même de repérer la
détresse de l'enfant et de recir sa
Parole nous attendons donc le plan que
vous avez annoncé et sa mise en œuvre et
nous aurons des propositions à vous
faire sur le sujet après le repérage
d'un cadeau harcèlement le traitement de
la situation est essentielle les retours
que nous avons des associations et des
familles montre encore que des progrès
peuvent être réalisés que les victimes
et leurs parents ne se sentent pas
suffisamment écoutés et soutenu
généraliser le programme PHARE manque de
moyens humains et financiers et repose
sur des dispositifs qui ne sont pas
encore assez explicites pour assurer une
vraie prise en charge dans les
établissements scolaires et une
meilleure orientation vers les
intervenants extérieurs
par ailleurs où nous avons beaucoup
parlé de la propulsion de loi de notre
collègue Marie Mercier proposition de
loi que nous soutenons fortement et
Alexandra borcio la répéter vous venez
de faire des annonces elles sont les
bienvenues nous attendons des mesures
précises l'essentiel est de toute façon
de régler la question en conclusion
monsieur le ministre nous attendons que
les recommandations du Sénat que la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Marie Mercier soit réellement prise en
compte dans le programme PHARE et
deviennent surtout effective sur le
terrain nous serons donc pas seulement
attentifs dans les prochains mois à la
mise en oeuvre de tout ce que vous avez
annoncé ce matin et répétez cet
après-midi la mobilisation ne doit pas
fléchir le Sénat vous accompagnera la
sérénité de tous nos élèves à l'école
est en jeu
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
l'ordre du jour rappelle la discussion
de la proposition de loi pour une école
de la liberté de l'égalité des chances
et de la laïcité présentée par Monsieur
Max Brisson et plusieurs de ses
collègues à la demande du groupe des
Républicains dans la discussion